city in the country i'm joined now by
the leader of the scottish national
party in blackford uh things developing
uh very quickly indeed but you must be
pleased that parliament has been
recalled
well of course i'm relieved that
parliament's been recorded or there's
anything that we should be pleased about
given the developments that are taking
place and by the way can i just
congratulate sky news for the coverage
that you're giving to this you've been
absolutely
first class this is a desperate
desperate situation
and i think first and foremost our
thoughts have to be with those that are
in afghanistan those that their human
rights are going to be
affected by this not least the women and
the children and
let's be clear they've been let down
we've let them down
we've departed in haste i understand it
wasn't the decision
that was taken by the uk it was a
decision taken by the us and we've had
to follow along and obviously questions
are going to have to be asked as to the
alternatives that were there but that's
past it's happened
and i think whilst
feeling deeply for those
afghanistans
also it's about those that have served
in iran forces those that have lost
their life those that have been injured
because i think many people will be
asking
what this has been for and of course
there are questions that now need to be
asked about the next steps what do we do
to try and give humanitarian support to
those
that need it but also the concerns that
many will have about a potential
bleeding ground for
terrorism and i hate to say it repeating
some of the the problems of the past so
on wednesday we will have that
opportunity in parliament and i heard
your piece just a little bit early it
will be on wednesday at 9 30 the
parliament will be convening and i've
asked the government that we can have a
debate
rather than a statement and we've got
the opportunity to
explore the issues
properly and i guess help to guide the
uk government and what it should be
doing in terms of its approaches both
with nato and with the united nations
because we need the united nations
security council to meet really with a
sense of of urgency to consider
next steps but this is a very
dark day and i and i hate to say this
for the west is perhaps the biggest
foreign policy setback since the
end of the
second world war and i guess over the
course of the coming hours and
very few few short days we need to make
sure
that those that are our citizens in
afghanistan those that we have worked
with that have worked with the uk
military
are evacuated at haste and amongst all
of that there are of course the the
issue of the
iraqi students that had been given
bursaries to uk universities
that this week were denied visas that
needs to be
fixed and fixed now so that we can give
sanctuary and safety to these people and
then finally with our partners we need
to consider what we will be doing to
support refugees in the region
and of course how many that we will be
taking in here ourselves
and
i suppose in addition to that
there's the impact that this will have
on regional security and the
implications that will for a number of
countries
not least for pakistan so this these are
very serious developments but these
developments are a consequence of the
political decisions that have been taken
over the course of the last few months
and frankly the wrong political
decisions